come on come on I'm going crazy up here
I can't take it anymore
tell me how much you missed me you know
how much I miss you I can't believe it's
been 20 years still gonna take father
into the anniversary we wouldn't be here
if it wasn't for him
this day in 1996 the world escaped the
clutches of extinction your father was
the bravest man I've ever seen we all
lost someone we loved but in their
sacrifice
we found the technology
to build a stronger
because our survival
only possible when we stand together we
found something out here something only
you might understand
oh my god
how did they get the lights we didn't
it happened on its own two days ago
twenty years ago when we destroyed the
mothership we detected a burst in an
expand frequency directed toward deep
space looks like someone picked up the
phone and said a distress call
they're coming back and it's definitely
bigger than the last one
it has it's a graphic
what goes up must come down shouldn't we
be nervous um yeah
why are they screaming they're not
screaming they're celebrating we could
use our isolation chamber that contains
the telepathy where's my dad
let me get in here so get about it
the over oldest system sir please unlock
the door don't you worry about me just
get as many answers as you can
who is she our whole lives built up to
this moment
it's touchdown over the Atlantic make
them pay
not going up there to make friends we've
gotten remind them earth is not for the
taking you are screwing with the wrong
species
I had years to get us ready
we never had a chance we didn't last
time either we convinced an entire
generation this is a battle that we
could win
we sacrifice for each other no matter
what the cost
that's worth fighting for support the
July let's show them some fireworks
they like to get the landmarks
at least your father spared the
elephants good for him
look the Roswell crash in 47 the farmer
who made contact drew the same so and
every time I interview one of my
patients and show them this they all
express the same emotion fear and I
don't think it's a circle the night the
ship turned on experienced the strongest
vision I've ever had
and I drew this
that's incredible how'd you decipher so
much in her language they were hunting
us we had to learn how to hunt them 20
years ago the world escaped the clutches
of extinction our survival is only
possible when we stand too
they're coming back
the aliens attack and we see if we can
do anything to salvage this devastation
there's a lot more of them and their
technology is even more advanced now
it's quite a Doug fun shouldn't we be
nervous
um yeah you've never seen world
destruction like this it'll touch down
over the Atlantic what sparked it it's
pretty incredible that means it's huge
20 years to get us ready I would never
had a chance you didn't last time either
my god
what goes up must come
don't worry ready controlled eyes
falling it's gone calling no control doc
they like to get the landmarks
- you out there and here at home
this is humanity's last stand what we do
in the next 12 minutes will either
define the human race or finish it we
are right now in Utah Salt Flats
it's the biggest Salt Flats in America
the salt flats was very beautiful you
know it's an otherworldly kind of a
gorgeous kind of thing and the soft side
you could drive as far as you want never
get there take your positions we have a
second alone this time to use it is the
last showdown
we go much grander scale it will be the
perfect spot to create the sequence
you're ready for close encounter
vodka
I've gotten worse much worse
mr. president dr. Okun you're awake
very much so why are they screaming no
no no that there they're not screaming
they're celebrating groaned Emmerich has
a unique sensibility and sense of humor
and flair for spectacle he's basically a
force of nature I spent 20 years trying
to get us ready for this
fall back
Rollins one of the best directors in the
world
he has a vision making the scale of
things so huge
oh you've never seen anything like this
on film before
why are they screaming they're not
screaming they're celebrating
shouldn't we be nervous um yeah make
them pay
we're gonna kick some serious butt
showing some fireworks
on behalf of the plane there's heavy
fourth of July
dependence day research and zuga pg-13
in theatres in IMAX 3d I spent 20 years
trying to get us ready for this dick
coming back they were hunting us we had
to learn how to hunt them we used their
technology strengthened our planet
but it won't be enough
Independence Day resurgence in theaters
and IMAX 3d twenty years ago the world
has gained the clutches of extinction we
must never forget our survival is only
possible when we stand together we have
found strength and unity as a planet and
that strength has brought us the power
to survive when the world was brought to
its knees the army was there to fight
back promised us that this would never
happen again they have been the driving
force in uniting nations around the
world to form the most powerful weapon
against another attack the earth space
defense
one
brave men and women of the ESD are
making sure the war of 96 will never
happen again
join earth space defense next time we
will be prepared an incredible piece of
technology 20 years ago a craft this
advanced would have been unimaginable
but so with the idea of
extraterrestrials attacking our planet
pushing mankind to the brink of
extinction as we near the 20th
anniversary celebration of the world's
victory we celebrate the heroes of the
war of 96 mankind that word should have
new meaning for all of us today we can't
be consumed by a petty differences
anymore president Whitmore's words
united us is a species and will
reverberate in our hearts forever we're
going to live on we're going to survive
today we celebrate our Independence Day
though our world had been reduced to ash
and rubble from those ashes would rise a
new age of growth technology and above
all unity in 1998 leaders from the
nations of the world joined together to
establish a global peace alliance
putting to rest centuries-old conflicts
and political distrust the newly united
nations would go on to form the united
global defense unit dedicated to the
protection of the earth against future
threats
David Levinson is today the director of
the earth space defense so many people
were lost as we know was a horrible
event in which much of the world
suffered and that's what's brought us
together
the SD has been an international
collaborative grand effort and our main
goal of course is to keep us safe and
I've taken a leadership role in
developing many aspects of this defense
system as you know it's taken a huge
effort to get a big military base on the
moon
and these orbiting units which have a
big punch to them 20 years ago these
weapons like the alien city destroyer
camp we used against us with devastating
results today we're utilizing them to
protect Earth as we got samples of their
more powerful technology and as much
else as we could we could enhance our
current arsenal and then figure out how
we could use space defensively if we had
to encounter somebody from afar but
let's not forget behind all of that
hybrid technology is the force of United
military one common enemy gave rise to
the human spirit the US Army along with
military forces from around the globe
joined the ESD growing up as the son of
a legend your path is pretty much set
becoming anything other than the best
fighter pilot was out of the question
I know I'd be proud of what we're doing
here we come from all over the world
with one goal be the best fighter pilots
in space it's a privilege to represent
my country China and to honor my parents
memory after the attacks in 96
it really was no room for feeling sorry
for yourself I lost someone we loved you
just did what you have to do get over
now I don't want them to come back but
if they do I feel pretty good about
getting one of these fighters and
blowing him out of the sky
the hybrid fighter is truly a marvel of
modern day engineering after
successfully identifying anti-gravity
devices on the alien spacecraft the ESDA
was able to use this new technology to
create a superior fighter jet it's
unclear as to whether ex-president
Whitmore will attend the 20th
anniversary event this year but let's
not forget the tireless warning that he
repeated in nearly every speech after 96
it's not a matter of if the aliens
return it's a matter of way
tell me how much you missed me you know
how much I miss you I can't believe it's
been 20 years still gonna take a shot
into the anniversary